what about the
the realm of ideas so like
you know i'm a big believer uh this guy
named cal newport
who wrote a book about deep work oh yeah
i love that book
yeah he's great so
he i mean one of the nice things i've
always
practiced deep work but he it's always
nice to have words
put to the the concepts that you've
practiced it somehow makes them more
concrete
and allows you to uh to get better it
turns into a skill that you can get
better at
but you know i also value deep thinking
where you think it's almost meditative
you think about a particular concept for
long periods of time
the programming you have to do that kind
of thing for you just have to hold this
concept
like like you you hold it and you take
steps with it you take further steps and
you
you're holding relatively complicated
things in your mind as you're thinking
about them
and there's a lot of i mean the hardest
part
is there's uh frustrating things like
you take a step and it turns out to be
the wrong direction so you have to
calmly turn around and take a step back
and then it's you're kind of like
exploring through the space of ideas
is there something about your study of
optimal performance
that could be applied to the act of
thinking
as opposed to action well we haven't
done
uh too much work there but what um but i
think i can comment on it yeah from a
neuroscience
yeah which is really all i do is uh well
i mean we do experiments in the lab but
looking at things through the lens of
neuroscience so what you're describing
um can be mapped fairly well to working
memory
just keeping things online and updating
them
as they change in information it's
coming back into into your brain
jack feldman who i'm a huge fan of and
fortunate to be friends with is a
professor at ucla
works on respiration and breathing but
he has a physics background
and um and so he thinks about
respiration and breathing in terms of
ground states and how they modulate
other states very very
interesting and i think um important
work
jack has an answer to your question
so i'm not going to get this exactly
right because this is lifted from a
coffee conversation that we had about a
month ago
but uh so um apologies in advance for
the
but i think i can get mostly right so we
were talking about this about
how the brain updates cognitive states
depending on demands
and thinking in particular and he used
an interesting example i'd be curious to
know if you
agree or disagree uh he said you know
most
great mathematics is done by people in
their
late teens and twenties and even you
could say
early 20s sometimes into the late 20s
but not much further on yeah
maybe i just insulted some
mathematicians no that's that's that's
true
and i think that it demands his argument
was um there's a tremendous demand on
working memory
to work out theorems in math and to keep
a number of plates spinning so to speak
mentally and run back and forth between
them updating them
in physics jack
said and i i mean i think this makes
sense to me too that
there's a reliance on working memory but
an increased reliance on some sort of
deep
deep memory and deep memory stores
probably stuff that's moved out of the
hippocampus and forebrain and into the
cortex
and is um more some episodic and
declarative stuff but really so
you're pulling from your library
basically it's not all ram it's not all
working memory
and then in biology that and physicists
tend to have
very active careers into their you know
30s and 40s and 50s and so forth
um sometimes later and then in biology
you see careers that
have a much longer arc these protracted
careers often
uh people still in their 60s and 70s
doing doing really terrific work
not always doing it with their own hands
because the people in the labs are doing
them of course but
and that work does tend to rely on
insights gained from having a very deep
knowledge base
where you can remember a paper and a or
maybe a figure in a paper you could go
look it up if you wanted to
but it's very different than the working
memory of the mathematician
and so when you're talking about coding
or being in that
tunnel of thought and trying to iterate
and keeping a lot of plates spinning it
it speaks
directly to working memory my lab hasn't
done too much of that working memory but
we are
pushing working memory when we have
people do things like these simple
lights out tasks
while they're under we can increase the
cognitive load
by increasing the level of autonomic
arousal to the point where they start
doing
less well yeah and you know everyone has
a cliff this is what's kind of fun we've
had
you know seal team operators come to the
lab we have people from other
units in the military very you know
we've had a
range of of intellects and backgrounds
and all sorts of things and
everyone has a cliff and those cliffs uh
sometimes show up as a function of the
demands of
speed of processing or
how many things you need to keep online
i mean we're all limited at some point
in the number of things we can keep
online
so what you're describing is very
interesting because it i think it has to
do with
how narrow or broad the information set
is
because and i don't program i'm not an
active programmer so
um this is a regime i don't really fully
know so i don't want to comment about it
uh in that in any way that you know
doesn't suggest that but i think that
what you're talking about
is top-down control so this is
prefrontal cortex
keeping every bit of reflexive circuitry
at bay
the one that makes you want to get up
and use the restroom the one that makes
you want to check your phone
all of that but also running these
anterior thalamus to prefrontal cortex
loops which we know
are very important for working memory
yeah let me try to think through this a
little bit
so reducing the process of thinking to
working memory access is tricky
he's probably ultimately correct but
if i were to say some of the most
challenging things
that uh an engineer has to do
an assigned a scientific thinker i would
say it's kind of depressing to think
that we do that best in our 20s but
is uh this kind of first principles
thinking
step of of saying
you you're accessing the things
that you know and then saying
well let me how do i do this differently
than i've done it before this
this weird like stepping back like
is this right let's try it this other
way
that that's the most mentally taxing
step
it's like you you've gotten quite good
at this particular
pattern of how you solve this particular
problem so there's a
there's a pattern recognition first
you're like okay
i know how to i build a thing that
solves this particular problem in
programming say
and then the question is
but can i do it much better and i don't
know if that's
i don't know what the hell that is i
don't know if that's accessing working
memory
that's that's almost access maybe it is
accessing memory in a sense it's trying
to find
similar patterns in a totally different
place that could be uh projected onto
this
but you're you're it's you're not
querying uh
facts you're querying like
functional things like yes patterns i
mean you're running out you're you're
testing algorithms
yeah right you're testing algorithms yes
so i want to just
um because i know uh some of the people
listening to this and you
have have basis and you know scientific
training and have scientific training so
i want to be clear
i think we can be correct about some
things like the role of working memory
in these kinds of processes without
being exhaustive we're not saying that
the only thing
you know we correct but not assume that
that's the only
thing involved right and i mean
neuroscience let's face it is still in
its infancy i mean we probably know one
percent of what there is to know about
the brain
um you know we've learned so much and
yet there may be global states that
underlie this that
make prefrontal circuitry work
differently than it would in it in a
different regime
or even time of day i mean there's a lot
of mysteries about this
but so i just want to make sure that we
we sort of are
we're aiming for precision and accuracy
but but we're not going to lose that
we're not going to be exhausted yeah so
there's a difference there and i think
uh
you know sometimes in the vastness of
the internet uh that gets forgotten
um so the other is that
um you know we think about
um you know we think about these
operations
uh at you know really focused keeping a
lot of things online but what you were
describing is actually
um it it speaks to the the
very real possibility probably that with
certainty
there's another element to all this
which is when you're trying out lots of
things in particular lots of different
algorithms
you don't want to be in a in a state of
very high autonomic arousal
that's not what you want because the
higher level of autonomic arousal and
stress in the system
the more rigidly you're going to analyze
space and time right
and what you're talking about is playing
with space-time dimensionality and i
want to be very clear
i mean i'm the son of a physicist i am
not a physicist when i talk about space
and time i'm literally talking about
visual space and how long it takes for
my finger to move from this point to
this point
you are facing a tiger and trying to
figure out how to avoid being eaten by
the tiger
and that's primarily going to be
determined by the visual system in
humans
we don't walk through space for instance
like a centowned wood
and look at three-dimensional scent
plumes you know when a scent hound goes
out in the environment
they have depth to their odor the odor
trails they're following
and they don't think about them if we
don't think about odor trails you might
say oh well the smell is getting more
intense aha
but they actually have three dimensional
odor trails so there you see a cone of
odor
c of course with their nose and their
olfactory cortex we do that with our
visual system and we parse
time often subconsciously with mainly
with our visual system also with our
auditory system and this shows up for
the musicians out there metronomes are a
great way to play with this
um you know bass drumming when the
frequency of bass drumming changes
your perception of time changes quite a
lot so
in any event space and time are linked
in the through the sensory apparatus
through the eyes and ears and nose and
um probably through taste too and
through touch um
for us but mainly through vision so when
you
drop into some coding or iterating
through a
creative process or trying to solve
something hard
you can't really do that well if you're
in a rigid
high level of autonomic arousal because
you're plugging in algorithms that are
in this space regime this time regime
matches it's space-time match
whereas creativity i always think the
lava lamp is actually a pretty good
example even though it has these counter
culture new
agey connotations because you actually
don't know which direction things are
going to change and so
in drowsy states sleeping and drowsy
states
space and time become dislodged from one
another somewhat and they're very fluid
and i think that's
why a lot of solutions come to people
after
sleep and naps
you